[Musique]
avec vous ce matin bilal par ab bonjour
bilal bonjour vous nous emmenez du côté
russe de la guerre en ukraine
aujourd'hui d'abord d'un point de vue
militaire et stratégique
comment est-ce qu'on peut résumer la
situation dans laquelle se trouvent les
russes à peu près après trois semaines
et demie hier en ukraine bah écoutez
globalement le front semble figé les
troupes russes n'avancent pas ou alors
est très très très peu j'imagine qu'on
va le voir sur la carte qui va
s'afficher la s'afficher à côté de moi
voilà donc les russes sont toujours
bloqués autour de kiev ici au nord-ouest
en banlieue dans une dans une banlieue
qui s'appelle airs ping est ici à l'ess
dans une banlieue qui s'appelle bovary
et on le voit depuis plusieurs semaines
ce sont deux localités qui résiste de
manière extrêmement déterminé face aux
russes et juste pour information ce sont
deux banlieues qui sont chacune à peu
près à à peine 15 km du centre ville de
kiev cherniff résiste toujours kharkiv
résiste toujours se feront ici aux dons
bassil est stable depuis le début de
l'offensive russe parce que ça fait il
faut le rappeler ça fait depuis 2014 que
l'armée ukrainienne est déjà en guerre
contre les séparatistes des républiques
de donetsk est lougansk des républiques
autoproclamées
sur le front sud alors on a des
bombardements aériens toujours sur
nicolas yves qui est la porte vers
odessa et bien sûr il y à la situation à
marioupol qui est toujours donc assiégée
par l'intérêt par la mer et ville dans
laquelle les russes ville dans laquelle
les russes sont entrés alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé les russes ont donné un
ultimatum aux ukrainiens pour que mario
paul capitulé en fait l'argument c'est
de demander aux ukrainiens d'être
raisonnable je me sens entre guillemets
cet argument a été enfin cette
proposition d'ultimatum a été rejetée
par l'ukraine ans qui dit qu'elle ne
déposera jamais les armes alors en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que là on rentre
dans le récit que font les russes de
cette guerre qu'il n'appelle d'ailleurs
pas une guerre mais une opération
militaire spéciale dans leur narratif
c'est à dire en fait finalement de faire
reposer là responsabilité des combats et
on les voit on c'est à dire des morts y
compris des morts civiles sur les
ukrainiens sur le fait que les
ukrainiens ne veulent pas être
raisonnable encore une fois je cite
entre guillemets et ne veulent pas
déposer les armes alors précisément sur
le narratif sur la rhétorique on l'a vu
encore ces jours ci le président poutine
ne varie pas d'un iota non pas du tout
on voit ici un ils commémoraient ce
vendredi les huit ans de l'annexion de
la crimée et donc il était alors là on
ne voit pas trop mais il était sous une
banderole qui disait non nazisme et
c'est toujours ce même vocabulaire le
nazisme on la voit ici l'excellent
cyrillique là donc c'est toujours le
génocide aux dons parce c'est la lutte
contre le fascisme c'est la lutte contre
le nazisme hors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que j'ai discuté hier avec une
russe qui m'a dit cette phrase qui est
assez saisissante elle me disait mais
vous les occidentaux vous découvrez sa
aujourd'hui alors que nous cela fait 20
ans qu'on vit dans ce théâtre et elle a
employé ce mot théâtre et quand on voit
la théâtralisation delà de la propagande
de vladimir poutine on comprend que
c'est un mot qui inquiet qui est lourd
de sens et je vous invite d'ailleurs à
relire anna politovskaïa qui est donc
cette journaliste russe d'opposition qui
a été assassinée en 2006 dès 2004 donc
dès la première élection de vladimir
poutine elle écrivait que vladimir
poutine se comporte comme staline qui
rappelons le s'est battu contre adolf
hitler et que les le poutine au pouvoir
s'était finalement le retour du système
soviétique en quelques mots bilal on y
reviendra peut-être plus largement à
8h30 le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky a sollicité ce week-end la
médiation d'israël qui en réalité tente
déjà de jouer les médiateurs dans ce
conflit qu'est ce qu'on peut penser de
cette proposition ukrainienne depuis
moscou alors écoutez très très
brièvement il faut déjà rappeler que
naftali bennett a été le premier
dirigeant étranger à se rendre à moscou
le 5 mars pour discuter avec vladimir
poutine très très vite israël et la
russie sont des pays qui sont
extrêmement proches en terme de
population 15 % des israéliens sont
russophones
israël aussi et ça c'est hier la pid le
ministre des affaires étrangères
israélien qui déclarait le 20 février
qu'en réalité israël a une frontière
commune avec la russie c'est à dire sa
frontière avec la syrie il ya des enjeux
qui sont extrêmement important pour
israël dans la région la russie un
levier sur israël puisque la russie
soutient l'iran soutient la syrie
al'inverse d'israël et donc finalement
pour ces raisons cumulées la russie
pourrait tout à fait avoir intérêt à
ceux acceptés ou se servir d'israël en
tant que médiateur